have you heard of a ghost product well  here's what it is and how it can make  you more money when i had a brick and  mortar chain i actually had a series of  retail products that i actually didn't  carry that existed on my purchasing menu  and so rather than saying hey go you  know pick from this menu instead i said  hey you don't need this one you can  probably find a cheaper version of it  you don't need this you can probably  find a cheaper version here don't worry  about it but what you really need is  this and this what happens is people  will trust you more if you try and save  the money up front in another way  because that way what you do is you show  your intention of trying to help the  prospect so what i did was i took that  and went extreme with it and just didn't  even carry the products so that i could  then gain the trust to make the sale to  help buy the products that they really  needed if you liked that video like  follow and comment i'll see in the next